welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new black adam movie
video there were a couple of big justice
society casting announcements recently
so we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know who else you want to see
show up during the black adam movie
i know everybody's hoping for henry
cavill's superman with the announcement
about him
appearing in future dc movies in a
couple different cameo roles
henry cavill also addressed that
directly because there's been a lot of
rumors about what's happening with the
future of the man of steel and the
superman solo movies
so we'll talk about that during the
video too but big stuff first they just
announced that noah centineo is actually
going to be playing
adam smasher in the justice society
during the movie
just confirming all the justice society
comments that have been made
they're going to be a couple twists with
the story for the justice society
because they're trying to be as comic
book accurate as possible so i'll
explain how it's going to work
because as you can see noah centennial
looks like a pretty young dude so he
makes it seem like the justice society
hasn't been around that long
when in fact the justice society that
we'll meet during the movie is actually
just going to be the new version of the
team
reforming after going dormant for a long
time so there'll be an older version of
the justice society that used to exist
long before the justice league ever came
together before superman ever came to
planet earth before batman donned the
cape and cow
you can't really count wonder woman
though because she's been around for
thousands of years
if you don't remember adam smasher they
actually did a version of that character
on the flash tv show during season 2
episode 1 played by edge himself
basically a character that grows really
big
and really strong
showtime if you don't know who noah
centineo is he's been doing a bunch of
netflix projects
recently so he's kind of blown up in the
public limelight he's also supposed to
play
he-man in the upcoming live-action
masters of the universe movie that
they've been trying to make for the last
couple of years
but with the exception of that big
justice league dark side war flashback
with a giant team up
the justice society of the dceu will be
canonically the first
real superhero team to come together
just a couple months ago the rock was
doing interviews
saying yes we will introduce the justice
society during the movie so if there
were any question about that the rock
himself has been talking about this
now they're just confirming some of the
castings and announcing who the
characters are going to be
within that same quote he also addresses
the other big dc characters
he's saying that they're on his radar
he's talking about the big trinity
superman batman wonder woman and of
course the flash aquaman
so even though the justice league as a
team isn't supposed to appear during the
blackout movie they will address those
characters in some way
they've been doing a version of the
justice society team on the star girl tv
show they've been syndicating that on
the dc streaming service
in the cw picked up the show too it's
actually moving to the cw for season two
but if you haven't seen it it's the
closest thing we have to a version of
the justice society in live action right
now
i told you to wait in the car
as you can see that show's doing most of
the original team members there's a lot
of easter eggs they haven't completely
finished the season yet so they haven't
revealed who their new version of green
lantern is going to be who's going to
wear the helmet of fate what's going on
with dr
fate in general a lot of it's brand new
there hasn't been a lot of justice
society in live action
since smallville and that was actually a
long time ago it doesn't seem like it
was that long ago but you may remember
they did a version of that during a big
two-parter
right now reportedly the justice society
characters that the black adam movie
will feature
in some way are adam smasher obviously
because of noah centennial
hawkman dr fate star girl the allen
scott green lantern of course
cyclone who's a relatively minor
character maybe
hawk girl and maybe the jay garrick
flash but that would also be one of
those situations where you sort of tie
that to the flash character because we
have the flash flashpoint movie that
they're still intending on making
everyone went crazy a little while ago
and they announced that michael keaton
was coming back as his batman from the
tim burton batman movies to be a batman
from the multiverse so that they're not
completely
retconning ben affleck's batman there's
a whole lot of batman stuff that's going
to be happening next year they'll be
filming the flash movie so we'll get way
more details on what's going on with
michael keaton's batman coming back
but you can kind of see now how the
black adam movie is slowly building
connections to other dc movies besides
the shazam movies because it's a direct
spin-off of the shazam movie
if they're going to do a version of the
jay garrick flash my assumption right
now is that they'll just explain it the
same way they explain the justice
society like how come they haven't
addressed this before how come we're
just now finding out about it
well reportedly the story is the classic
team the original version
helped the younger version of the wizard
shazam trap black adam a long time ago
the team was shattered and they
basically went dormant for a long time
eventually black adam escapes in present
day and a new team has to reform the
justice society
and help take him down but here's the
thing black adam isn't supposed to be
the main villain of his own movie he's
supposed to be the protagonist more of
like an anti-hero character
so they'll probably just have a lot of
fun with that the whole idea that the
justice society thinks that he's the
villain and tries to stop him but the
movie portraying him is more of the hero
the whole problem with that is that you
have to make him sympathetic you have to
explain what happened to his wife
i've done a couple videos about his
backstory in the comics and how they're
adapting versions of black adam the dark
age from the comics
that's just about how he tries to get
his powers back and tries to resurrect
his dead wife
the rock himself actually started
developing the black adam movie
long before they decided to do a shazam
movie and originally he was going to
debut
during the first shazam movie but the
way the rock tells it is that when they
were initially developing the movie
years ago because he's tried to do black
adam for the last 10 years that's how
long he's been black adam
he said that there was just way too much
story to cover they couldn't do the
black adam origin story
and the shazamly origin story in the
same movie
and have it feel like a coherent story
so they just decided to split them into
two different movies and went with the
shazam movie first to explain who shazam
was and then
explain who black adam was it also
doesn't help that the rock has like a
billion other movies that he's making so
there's been a lot of stuff that's
gotten in the way of them actually doing
the black adam movie but they are going
to start filming it later this year it's
supposed to come out december
2021 there was also a report recently
that they're going to try and develop a
spin-off movie
for the new version of the justice
society with the characters that they
introduced during the black adam movie
if things go well
with the black adam movie a lot of it
just depends on how it does at the box
office
worst case scenario the rock is really
good at getting people into theaters so
the movie will probably do
at least venom numbers if not better i
think that's a good comparison to make
because they turned venom a villain from
the comics into more of an anti-hero
with tom hardy's version of the
character it actually did really well in
the box office
but as for the big superman crossover
you guys probably saw earlier today
henry cavill was posting video of
himself building a superhero pc during
the quarantine lockdown period
he's been doing a bunch of superman
justice league interviews recently
what he said though is that a lot of
people aren't 100
correct on all the superman rumors about
what he's working on behind the scenes
what warner brothers is working on
in terms of the future of the superman
character he didn't really clarify
what's correct and what's wrong
but right now the report is is that he's
working on coming back for a couple of
minor roles in crossover films
and eventually maybe if things go well
with those movies he will eventually do
a new superman solo movie
when hollywood reporter deadline variety
all the big hollywood trades were
reporting about the future crossover
movies that he was negotiating for
they mentioned the flash flashpoint
movie the black adam movie that's why
you've been seeing all the fan art of
superman vs black adam
shazam 2 in aquaman 2. so that's why
you've probably been hearing a lot about
those movies in particular but i think
right now it's still up in the air and
when he says that people aren't 100
correct on what's going on behind the
scenes i think what he's mostly talking
about
is the movies in question in what his
appearances would look like when he does
show up as superman
so hopefully they'll make some big
announcements about that around dc
fandom next month when they do all the
big comic-con panels
most of the big hype around that event
is going to be focused on the justice
league snyder cut just because it's one
of the next really major movies that dc
is releasing even though it's releasing
it in a really creative way on hbo max
i've already done a bunch of videos
about that then there's wonder woman
which is still supposed to come out in
october right now hopefully that date
sticks and they don't have to delay it
even more
there's a lot of question about what's
happening with movie theaters for the
rest of the year
there is a brand new superman man of
tomorrow movie the dc just released if
you're looking for new dc
content i recommend checking it out it's
a totally different animation style
and if you haven't seen it yet be sure
to check out justice league apocalypse
war
probably one of the best dc animated
movies the last couple of years
but that movie is meant to be the end of
that line of continuity with that
version of the justice league and those
voice over actors in the dc animated
universe
so while the new dc animated movies will
have slightly different animation style
it'll be different voiceover actors
playing the main characters like batman
superman wonder woman
but everyone let me know in the comments
what are you most excited to see in the
black adam movie
i really just want to see the rock just
start pounding the crap out of a bunch
of big dc characters i can't wait to see
the rocks black adam versus hawkman wait
you wait for everything click here for
that really cool video of henry cavill
building that custom gaming pc during
the lockdown
and click here for that last big justice
league snyder cut trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you